along with the phrases integration of my
parts and uniform circular motion there
are a few things that make you feel more
like an extension to student than being
able to say yeah I know what complex
numbers are okay now that's what's
strange and really powerful it's
powerful because most people by the time
they get out of the end of this topic
they feel a bit like a like neo in the
matrix there's this famous scene where
he finds out that he can just load
whatever knowledge he wants in the world
that exists just directly into his brain
and they load all of this martial arts
knowledge and skill into his own mind
and he wakes up and he looks at Laurence
Fishburne's character and he says you
know I never come through and you kind
of come out of the end of this topic
feeling like wow I know all of this
secret knowledge that seems really crazy
and easy Terry I had to understand the
outside but now I'm on the inside right
so it's powerful but it should also feel
philosophically very strange because for
like 12 years of your schooling career
you've never known about these and
you've done a whole lot of maths and to
be honest like 99% more than 99% of the
world's population doesn't know that
these things exist and they get along
just fine so while this is a recruit of
a powerful idea and shouldn't we do our
a little bit that we're spending so much
effort on something which most people
don't even know about okay so why are we
why are we going to look at something
which is it's so obviously not really
you know normal everyday knowledge why
are we going to spend so much time and
effort understanding this and it's
actually quite a simple answer it all
depends on one of these and this is a
string cuz you can see on over the
screens not super bright at the moment
it's a string now to understand why this
is relevant we need to back up a little
bit okay I wonder how many of you
recognize what these are again it's a
bit dim these are four symbols that well
I think these particular ones
from the avatar series they represent
water fire wind or air and okay now it's
not just the avatar series that has come
up with these ideas ever since ancient
times human beings societies have wanted
to know what is the universe around us
what's it made of what's the stuff that
everything consists of and wind fire air
earth is has been one of the common
ancestors of that throughout all kinds
of consciousness civilizations people
follow these are kind of like the
elements that make up everything around
us okay but as you can imagine we have
progressed quite always since thinking
that the world is made of this stuff for
example was the ancient Greeks who they
thought of the world around them as
built of this thing called the the
atonement right now and when you put an
A as a prefix in front of a wound like a
symmetrical or atheist or something like
that it means not right or you can't hey
not and then this part it means
basically to cut right to cut so putting
it all together this means something
that's indivisible right but ancient
Greeks saw everything in the universe
was made up of some indivisible object
which is why when the chemist John
Dalton when he came up with a similar
kind of theory and found out
scientifically yeah there are these
things he named them atoms okay now just
pause for just pause think about imagine
you were John Dalton okay and you had
conceived with the atom you it can't
aside to be evidence to prove that it
exists and then someone comes to you and
says who cares who cares it's like most
people don't even know that atoms exist
you can't you can't see them like in our
normal way with your eyes you can't
perceive them most people do not exist
know that these exist I never knew they
existed
till now and my life has been fine for
all of these years up until now so so
what's the point of you know working
what these things are and understanding
them now I wonder if you would John
Dalton how you reply to that what would
be your response as to why you should
care about Adams when your daily
experience isn't you know doesn't matter
where you know about it or not and it's
kind of hard to overstate how much our
understanding of Adams has kind of
changed the world around us and change
the world in which we inhabit just think
about it unfortunately it's not super
clever agriculture medicine energy
technology transportation and of course
war right all of these have been changed
by human humanity's understanding of the
atom okay so to think just because you
can't see these and just because you can
get by in your life without knowing that
these exist that doesn't mean the face
don't have a profound impact on the life
that you know and that if you can
understand them they help you grapple
with this world in a much better much
more profound way okay in addition to
just all the practical stuff we just
want to know we want to know what the
universe is made of and so as you guys
are aware we didn't just stop with atoms
despite the name right just despite
Dalton's discovery atoms are in fact
divisible with some disastrous effects
sometimes right after atoms you can
break them down into further particles
right and even these guys even these can
be broken down I mean electrons are
elementary so you can't break them down
but protons and neutrons
they're made of quarks right o'clock's
down quite strange charm
the names for these things they're
divisible to write and currently the
best theory that we have scientifically
for what happens if you keep on digging
down and digging down in dd-down is that
everything in the universe is made up of
strings that's what they call the
objects of the name for them they're
these we'd one-dimensional vibrating
strings that make up everything in the
universe okay in complex numbers complex
numbers are the strings of the
mathematical universe in the same way
that these are you know the fundamental
building blocks of the material universe
okay so why are we trying to understand
this why are we gonna spend so much time
and effort believe me
you fool water in this is hard okay it's
because we want to know we want to know
what the universe is may not not just
materially but mathematically and also
just like with these guys the
implications the practical work out
workings of complex numbers are
widespread and profound in fact they're
just as much a part of your everyday
experience as understanding the atom